العواجل تتوالى طبعا بخصوص هذه المحاكمه
احتجاز ترامب بالمحكمه لاخذ بصمته ايضا
البيت الابيض يقول
مستعدون لاي تهديد
هذا هذا الموقف من البيت الابيض الذي رفض
التعليق على القضيه ولكن قال انهم مستعدون
لاي تهديد نقف عند كلمه اي تهديد ما
التهديد المحتمل عن اي تهديد يتحدث البيت
الابيض
برايك
انا لا فكره لدي على الاطلاق عن اي تهديد
هل قلتم ان البيت الابيض يتحدث عن تهديد
هذه اخبار مفاجئه تماما
رغم انا عندي الثقه الكامله بكم لكن لا
اعتقد ان هذا سيحصل اليوم او ما يشبه ما
حصل في السادس من يناير عندما حرض عليه
دونالد ترامب هو على مدى اليومين الماضيين
على الاقل
استمع الى نصائح فريق القانوني المشكل
حديثا والذين نصحوه بان يلتزم الصمت لكي
لا توجه اليه التهم اخرى بتحريض ما يسمونه
بالجرذان في الشوارع الامريكيه اي انصاره
من الغوغائيين وطبعا
الان يجمع ملايين الدولارات من خلال
تصريحاته
بسبب هذه التهم هذه الاموال يستخدمها
دونالد ترامب لكن هي تجمع من امريكيين هم
ينتمون الى قاعدته الانتخاب اسرارهم
يؤمنون بكل كلمه ينطق بها اذا هو على
المدى القريب وانا اؤكد على المدى القريب
سيستفيد من لائحه التهم وهو الان
يتقلب بنعم الله من تاييد كبير له في
اوساط الحزب الجمهوري لكن على المدى
البعيد سنرى سنرى
كما تدين تدان كما يقولون ولا شيء يتغير
مثلما تتغير الامور في